as the button administration feels
bipartisan blowback from their botched
afghanistan withdrawal one fact remains
vice president kamala harris has all but
disappeared from public view the second
in command who bragged about being the
last person in the room has hardly
commented on the crisis and that may be
on purpose fox news contributor joe
koncha labeling kamala harris as the
absentee vp by design saying this quote
since harris took office she has yet to
hold even one formal solo press
conference not one and it's also been
weeks since harris sat down for a
one-on-one interview there's a reason
for that
greg is kamala harris a liability for
the biden administration or are they a
liability to her future political career
at this point i have a theory but first
i want to let everybody know that on
gutfeld tonight we'll be doing an
in-depth investigation into her
whereabouts just a key hint
we haven't found her so but there'll be
a lots of uh of uh new breaking in
where's ronaldo yeah exactly she went
from the star pupil you know to the
weird ant you keep in the attic she went
you know it's it's an amazing transition
and it is so fast voters voted basically
most likely to be president she could
barely get free wi-fi at arby's so i
don't i don't know okay my theory
where's my theory i have a theory i
wrote down here okay here's my theory
the administration got bad so fast
keeping her hidden is preferable
so she doesn't get smeared by joe's
failures so she's behind the glass like
an axe so they're just waiting for the
right time to break the glass and and
take her out and we really don't know
how bad she is but we're gonna have the
democrats are gonna assume it can't be
any worse than this that's my theory
no
no i like your theory i have a feeling i
know when they're gonna break that glass
they're gonna pull it out when racial
politics make their way back to the
forefront of the national conversation
if i'm kamala harris right now i'm
extremely offended because you have been
used they used you to pander to a voting
base to get votes they had a minority
they had a woman and now that they don't
need her they have shelved her because
her approval rating is negative 19. it's
clear that whenever she's out front she
does hurt she is a liability to the
administration but if i'm kamala harris
i'm saying well i wasn't a liability for
you joe i guess when you needed to get
elected so
i think kamala has a right to be very
very upset but the buy demonstration is
in a very tough position do we admit
that we used kamala to get elected or do
we run her back out and hurt our numbers
the way hers have plummeted
until the anger and rage over this
afghanistan withdrawal fades hopefully
it doesn't hopefully the american people
remember
they've got to keep her hidden because
she's clearly not very good on her feet
with
lester holt you know i haven't been to
europe and when she cut off the female
journalist she's not a good enough liar
she can't tap dance around this disaster
well enough to put her out there in
public my opinion herald i i think that
you remember and you have to remember
her historic significance
black woman first south asian first
woman
in the
in the white house
remember that and remember the burden
that she carries and remember how she
was so misused on the southern border
they sent her to guatemala they did they
they totally
dictated her movements and she took the
fall for it now she is so negative uh
negatively perceived now her
popularity i read was 34
so that's extraordinarily low for
someone so historic who was supposed to
prop up old joe so i think that what
this is now is a pragmatic ruthlessly
pragmatic decision keep her on the on
the low
lowdown right now
when the time comes if it is about
racing you always bring her back but she
proved that she can't handle herself in
those interviews
shannon well again she okay she's got
the crown on her head i'm not making but
she's got to keep it there and it you
know she stepped on it yeah but think
about this um i think will has a great
point she was a great fit for this
ticket obviously checked some serious
boxes and it was exciting it was
historic for a lot of people but
remember during the primaries she never
caught on fire she wasn't great in the
the primary debates she wasn't pulling
well she couldn't raise money she had to
drop out so while she was a good fit on
the ticket whether she can be a good
leader and manage things well is a
totally different question and so far
she's gotten the worst assignment which
is the border um and so that's going to
be a difficult thing for any vice
president because it's an unsolvable
problem she's probably going to be a
professional tiebreaker given what's
going on in the senate that's what she's
going to do in washington is go up there
and break ties whenever it matters um
but it's not like she showed during the
primary process that the american people
loved what she had to say substantively
or that she was up to taking that next
step well even
did you have something you want to say i
was going to say i miss her laugh
um what it was always bright in my day
whenever she would laugh
now
yes it is it is but i keep thinking do
you guys watch storage wars i keep
thinking i'm going to watch an episode
and they're going to open up a container
and she's going to leap out that shows
how kinky you are that you want stories
hiding in there yes jump out no no
that's not kinky nanny day fiance is
king oh don't even get me started yeah
exactly naked and afraid
necklace in the show too it's naked and
scared is how we say it
that's our version greg gregg
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else